the main reason why oil prices are
falling is that we had a stretch of time
where we had rising supply from North
America matched by falling supply from
other places because of developments in
Libya developments in Iraq developments
in Iran and the run of bad supply
developments has largely stopped and the
positive supply developments in the
United States have continued and the
expectation that that will continue in
the future is leading to a significant
decline in the price of oil my guess and
guesses about oil prices are highly
problematic is that they're going to
stay down since it seems to me there's
probably more room for positive supply
surprises from here than there is for
negative supply surprises no one really
knows the price sensitivity of tight oil
shale type oil in the United States my
best guess would be that at prices above
$60 the broad trend towards increasing
u.s. supplies will continue and so I
think we are making progress towards
energy independence though I think
energy independence is a somewhat
complex goal and may mean less than
presidents of the United States have
often implied that it means Japan and
Europe remain dependent on Middle East
oil and it is hard to believe that we
could ever allow a situation to
materialize where there was a vast
difference in price between the price of
oil in Japan and Europe and the price in
the United States and so if one asks the
fun
mental question is the world price of
oil vulnerable to what happens in the
Middle East the answer to that question
is probably somewhat less than it was
but it is still very vulnerable to what
happens in the Middle East and in that
sense even if the United States stops
being a net importer of oil it will
still be very vulnerable and can't
really be said to be energy independent